israel's president isaac hatson is in
germany for events commemorating the
1972 munich olympics massacre in the
past hour he has been addressing the
parliament here in berlin hedzog
underscored the importance of
remembrance a day after germany
apologized for mishandling the munich
massacre 50 years ago in which 11
israeli olympic team members died
touching on germany and israel's
relationship today he urged both
countries to fight anti-semitism
together and not to forget the past
it is not easy to critically engage with
remembrance
to put the past behind them
in israel too remembrance is painful
[Music]
whether we want it or not the
remembrance of the holocaust is a
quintessential part of our identity
but our remembrance of these atrocities
is not easy
our chief political correspondent
melinda crane has been following
president hedzog's speech is with me
here in the studio melinda the
importance of remembrance was that the
main point of hand sonic speech it was
but in conjunction with uh the
responsibility that is entailed that
comes from that
remembrance and in that sense he talked
about the remembrance as not only a duty
to the victims of the holocaust the
shoah but also as a duty to the future
to ensure of course that such crimes
will never be
repeated and in that context he quoted
his own father in a very moving way his
father was not only the first israeli
president to speak to the bundestag in
1987
so 35 years
prior to this but also was with the
british armed forces that freed the
concentration camp bergen-belsen which
president herzog this president hatzo
will visit later on and he said that his
father said about
that uh freeing of bagon belzon that
only the victims themselves have the
right to forgive but that all of us have
the duty to remember for their sake but
also uh with the implications in terms
of responsibility for the future
so a lot of remembrance uh but also
again looking forward the israeli
president touched on geopolitics at uh
towards the end of his speech he
referred to iran's nuclear ambitions
what do you say about that indeed he did
and he basically did derive a german
responsibility uh from the crimes of the
holocaust also in regard to stopping
iran
as he said he said iran is dedicated to
israel's destruction he said that same
thing by the way when he met
german president steinmeier on sunday
and that the accord currently being
negotiated by germany and other powers
to try to get iran to return to the 2015
nuclear deal
he said on sunday uh in somewhat more
direct uh speech is toothless and
watered down and that it must be stopped
somewhat more diplomatically he uh
indicated the same here to the bundestag
today
a very important moment in german
israeli relations right now we've seen a
compensation agreement for the victims
of the munich olympics massacre finally
agreed after so long what does all this
say about german israeli relations right
now melinda well the reason that we're
hearing not only the two speakers today
stress the duty to remember and the
special responsibility that germany has
to israel but also yesterday at the
commemoration in munich at the airfield
where the israeli hostages most of them
were killed two were killed in the
olympic village of course but the reason
we're hearing this stressed so
forcefully by all of the speakers is
that in fact we are seeing a divergence
in german and israeli attitudes when it
comes to exactly this point with the
majority of israel israelis saying this
is an ongoing responsibility that
germany has for the jewish people and
for the israeli state whereas a minority
of germans see it that way and in fact
nearly half of germans say it's time to
draw a line under history that
will be regarded by many many uh people
including within the german political
leadership with alarm as will a further
finding of a recent study that fully a
quarter of germans say that jews have
too much power in the world an
anti-semitic trope that clearly is being
fomented by social media by hate site
sites hate speech sites and that's one
reason we heard the president of the
bundestag today emphasizing the
importance of political leadership to
fight ingrained anti-semitism which she
said is at the heart
of german political culture or german
culture in many ways
melinda thank you so much our chief
political correspondent melinda crane
you